All right, so here's another state.
I just transported you randomly
to another start state, and
you claim that you understand
how things work now.
So can you explain?
>> I think I do.
The goal is to go get
the little yellow circle or
the circle which was yellow
to begin with the last time.
I don't know if that means anything.
And I
>> I think it was green last time.
>> Was it?
And you want to pick it up,
which was I think 5.
And when you do that, what I don't yet
know is whether it will change color.
But whatever color it
is when you pick it up,
you want to take it to the square
that matches that color.
>> Okay.
>> Then put it down, which is Action 1.
Now I should say, because I didn't say
it before, that what I thought the point
was the first time was just to get the
square and the circle in the same place.
>> The square and the circle.
Yeah, you did that.
But you didn't get any reward for that.
>> Right, so then I figured out
maybe I didn't do anything but
at that time I was also just trying to
figure out what all the commands did.
>> Good.
>> I was doing a lot of exploring.
>> All right, so learned a bit
about the transition function,
you learned a little about how
actions change the state and
you also learned a little bit
about what states are rewarding.
>> Yes.
>> And so now you think even though
things are a bit different you think you
can actually get kind of on
a minimal path to a gold state now?
>> Sure.
So from here I would go 3,3.
Then I would go 4,4 then
5 which keeps it yellow.
So then I need to go as
quickly to yellow as I can.
There's a lot of ways of doing that but
let's just do 2,2.
6,6,6,6.
2,2.
And then that doesn't work.
>> Is it possible you forgot something?
>> Oh, 1, I forgot to put it down.
>> Boom!
>> Done.
>> All right, so good excellent job.
So that was an MDP and in fact,
you solved that a lot faster than any of
the algorithms [LAUGH] that
we're going to be talking about.
Because you made use of all kinds of
interesting background information about
how you can- What navigation does and
how it's consistent across states.
But generally in the MDP model and
the reinforcement learning model,
we don't necessarily assume that.
It could very well be that what you're-
In each state, the actions all do some
other kind of crazy different thing,
and you have to learn that mapping.
>> Right, so let me say two things.
Actually three thing.
One, is when I trying to figure out
what the actions were, I considered for
a moment, even though I had already
figured out that 3 moves you right,
I considered trying to go right a couple
of times just to see if there was any
randomness [CROSSTALK].
>> Mm.
But then I decided you wouldn't do that
to me, you're too nice of a person.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And so
I decided they were deterministic and
then do that.
But you point out that yeah,
I did it kind of fast because I
had a lot of background knowledge.
I'd really say that it was
more about assumptions.
>> Okay.
>> And
in fact my first assumption was wrong.
Oh.
>> The goal was just to get in
the same place as the circle and
that was the whole point.
>> That's true.
>> And
then the last thing I'll say is that
as long I've been thinking
about reinforcement learning.
As long as I've been thinking
about search algorithms and AI.
As long as I've been machine learning I
don't think I ever really appreciated
how incredibly frustrating it is
[LAUGH] when you don't actually know
what the rules are and you're just
trying to figure out what's going on.
And I now am going to be much kinder
to all of my search algorithms.
>> That's what I was hoping
you'd get out of that.
Thank you.
Yes.
So sometimes it's really frustrating
watching these algorithms do what
they do.
And in some cases just repeatedly
bashing their heads against the wall.
Which for what it's worth is
something that you didn't do.
When you were moving around in the grid,
you were purposely avoiding
these black lines.
Do you know why?
[LAUGH] Maybe those
are actually reward lines.
If you bump into them you win.
>> Yeah, but every time I've ever
played any game, they're walls.
>> Yeah, they look like walls.
And, in fact, they are in this case.
So that again, that was an assumption
that you brought to bear.
But, right, so when you watch a learning
algorithm, reinforcement learning
algorithm actually interacting
with a grid like this.
It doesn't have those
biases necessarily.
And so it can actually bash its
head against this wall, and
then maybe this wall for a while,
and hey, this wall looks really fun.
And so, yeah,
it's good that we have a little bit
of empathy for the poor reinforcement
learning agent that's trying to master
this environment given very complex and
hard to parse apart representations for
the actions and the states.
>> Hmm, that's very good.
Probably the only thing more
frustrating than my trying to play this
was all the people watching
me trying to play this.
>> Oh, I think they loved it.
For what it's worth,
we can make this available.
>> [LAUGH] Who would play
it on their home computers?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, but now they know the answer.
Can you just like randomly
change what the actions are?
>> Let's say that I did that.
>> Okay, that was actually quite good.
I'm glad you didn't let me
know what it was before hand.
>> [LAUGH] Do you recognize it now?
Do I recognize what now?
It's a taxi cab to me.
I almost said that [LAUGH] and then
realized that would break the illusion.
>> [LAUGHTER] So when I had Molly
do this a long a time ago, and
I asked her at the end.
What is exactly the task that
this is supposed to be doing?
She's like well you have
to rescue the dog, and
it just wants to go to its house.
Wow, that is-
>> Yeah,
I thought that was kind of awesome.
>> We should try that with
my daughter and see if,
assuming she can sit still long enough,
and see what she would come up with.
>> The other thing is when
you had in this position and
you really like the kind of
symmetries of it and stuff.
We actually did this in a mall in New
Jersey where we had people come by and
just see what they would do.
You'd give them the game and they'd.
And there was one woman who was a real
estate agent, who could just not
get over the idea that the actual
goal is to fix the Feng Shui.
So if you look there's
a color in every corner,
except the blue is not
quite in the corner.
So she kept trying to move
the blue into the corner.
>> And when I told her that she should
stop doing that, she just kept doing it
because [LAUGH] she was convinced
that the task was one of feng shui.
>> I like that.
>> Yeah.
>> And that tells you everything you
need to know about why our real
estate market is the way it is.
[LAUGH]
>> And New Jersey.